luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and me and my brother dan here
we are searching for she fish that's
right we're going ice fishing on the
chuck cheese sea above the arctic circle
and we're going to be camping and
catching massive fish come along for the
ride it's going to be awesome
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we made it to ludwig
hotel here in kotzebue
and we're about 30 miles north of the
arctic circle on the chuck cheese sea
[Music]
there we go that's the frozen ocean
right there we gotta go find ourselves
some snow machines and get some supplies
because we are going out there and we're
going to be camping and fishing and it's
going to be pretty awesome so um
yeah you know you're in the alaska bush
when
they have kennels and straw for your dog
team in the hotel parking lot
nice
yeah got your caribou hides
got the caribou meat sitting on the
front porch keeping it nice and cool
oh
what you need to know about harvesting
polar bears in kotzebue oh and a rabies
reminder don't feed or approach foxes
[Music]
we'll get oranges
all sold out of milk but it looks like
it was going for 650 a gallon it's not
bad
it's packaged here reindeer roast
here we go
we got shelf life milk here six bucks we
got some cereal and bagels for breakfast
tomorrow because i don't think there's
anywhere we can get breakfast
we're gonna go and try to grab some
dinner look at this
solid blocks of jade just
sitting here all right guys we're gonna
grab some dinner here at the empress so
they do chinese food
everything everything we're getting a
little bit of everything all right we
got uh sesame chicken nachos supreme and
a philly cheesesteak sandwich a little
bit of everything
and oh there's ketchup in there i
ordered a philly cheesesteak sandwich
and nachos and i got a fortune cookie
that's awesome
this is a fair representation of
restaurants in rural alaska
it's 11 20 at night and uh i can still
see outside
it's that time of year where the days
are getting real long but uh it's late i
gotta get to bed so i'm gonna see you
guys in the morning
well good morning it is a beautiful day
here in kotzebue
well my brother's here for a work trip
so today he's got to go do grown-up
stuff tiffany time
dad tiffany time
so while he's doing that i'm going to
explore the town a little bit and i'm
going to try to go scout out some ice
fishing spots i'll see you there
but with a little over 3 000 people this
is a major hub here in the northwest the
next big town is gnome which is about a
35 minute flight south of us but there's
lots of little interesting things about
bush life here in alaska
first off you'll notice that all the
houses are on stilts the ground here is
frozen it's all permafrost and if you
build your house straight on the ground
you'll thaw out the permafrost it'll
turn into mush and your house will sink
so all the houses all the buildings are
built on stilts the real large buildings
like the hospital the school the hotel
they have to be built on refrigerated
pilings it makes living and building up
here really expensive so this is
springtime here in kotzebue right now
it's april and the highs are about 35
degrees but just a few days ago it was
negative 40. so the weather can be all
over the place one of the things to see
in town is the national park service
northwest alaska heritage museum let me
go check it out
check it out this is what we're after
that's a she fish it's a native fishing
pole
there's a salmon drying racks in the
springtime you'll see these on the beach
out here in kotzebue
all right this is where kotzebue is
right here and you can see these are all
the different new pick nations
different tribes
fermented seal flipper that's a
traditional food they still do
traditional subsistence whale hunting
and seal hunting here about a year ago i
got to eat some seal meat and drink some
seal oil with dan while ice fishing
it's a powerful taste
check it out that's a harpoon head
that's an arrow shaft straightener
all right i think it's time to go look
for some she fish see if you can't find
out where these fish
well i'm out here on the sea ice and i'm
just cruising around looking for piles
of fish guts if you want to know which
hole to fish look for the one with the
most guts around it
there's a big pile of fish heads here
these guts have been here a while
you can see how they've melted down into
the snow so they've probably been here
at least a couple days
this right here is a herring this is
what the she fish eat
so i'm gonna save this for bait
this looks like a place people have been
going to get lots of bait
well i've been running the snow machine
for about an hour across the sea ice
and i was told that i might want to look
over this way
i could be wrong but that looks like the
hood of a truck
i think i can see where somebody's been
digging ice holes
we go check those out
i'm looking for an ice hole covered in
fish guts
somebody's marked their fishing hole
with a branch so they can find it again
even with the snow drift
here's a traditional fishing ring i got
a little caribou antler with some 80
pound test line wrapped around it a big
old spoon we're gonna drop that down
there see if we can catch a sheet fish
maybe three minutes
no matter where you go in the world it's
the same questions have you caught
anything how deep is it
no action on this hole so we're gonna
try another
someone strung a gill net under the ice
you got this
over there
i am going to try punching my own hole
so
all right they don't seem to be here
gotta keep trying spots
hahaha
that is a little tom cot
i should have made some decent bait
so this is a tom cod
it looks a lot like a pacific cod but a
little skinnier they don't get very big
makes tiny little fish and chips but i'm
going to keep a few of them for bait
maybe a few to eat
i can't believe i'm ice fishing on the
ocean right now
that looks like a hooligan or something
got so many of those it's like every 15
20 seconds landed one of those little
tom cots
[Applause]
all right my brother got done with his
day job stuff
so we're gonna head back out and we're
gonna see if we can't find those fish
i've been talking to all the fishermen
we meet along the way no one's having
much luck over here
i think our best bet
is to go inland
all the way up to the mouth of the koa
buck river and see if we can see anyone
having luck over there
oh that's crazy
we're gonna head back we thought maybe
you guys got him out
we
definitely did not any down there
nothing not everybody i've talked to all
the way from here to costco nobody's
seen it
what's that
that's that's that's my camera you want
to see it
yeah it's for making youtube videos ah
days on good doesn't it yeah it does
doesn't fall off if it has a little no
it doesn't it's it's real tough seeing
you
oh thank you very much
all right we got we got she fished in
been pointed the right direction at this
point if we can't catch one that's just
it's just nothing but shame
uh
all right we are going to use the
time-tested tactic of finding somebody
who knows what they're doing and setting
up close to them
and doing exactly what they told us
all right let's see if we can catch one
ourselves
what
is it a small one
a flounder
we really are ice fishing on the ocean
isn't that weird
there you go crazy
we haven't gotten a single bite so we're
gonna try moving down just a little bit
see if we can find them
so
a little bit of sea fish chin there
i got one
look at that
my brother's coming over here so quick
look at that beauty
oh my goodness look what it did to that
barb
it bent that
there we go my very first she fish
oh yeah that's not bad dan you want me
to get you another hole right over here
yes i do all right let's do it one thing
the last ones know to do is fish next to
someone close yeah we do
[Music]
i don't want to stick my hands in it
oh you got one that one
yeah there you go okay
i grabbed the hood
got the hook grab the hook instead of
the line
i'm gonna try oh
that's a big one dad it's a bigger one
that's a nice guy that is a nice sheep
[Music]
look at that
that is gorgeous dad that looks like 20
pounds ish
maybe a little over
oh that's another beauty dad
show me those fish
holy fact
those are beauties buddy look at that oh
you had to put them next to mine oh look
at this look at those beasts
those she fish messed up some of those
hooks
i tell you this has been awesome but i
do not want to make my way back in the
dark so i think we need to pack it up
we're going to be doing a lot more of
this tomorrow
and it's getting cold the temperature's
dropping rapidly and we have a long trip
[Music]
oh
i've got a fish to give away native
villages there's a tradition that when a
young man makes his first kill he gives
it away
to the people who helped him and taught
him so since i got my first shift today
i'm gonna give it away to the family who
loaned us these snowmobiles and made it
possible
when do you get
you got three oh wow
hey one for you yep hey thanks again
thank you thank you
oh
my back is stiff
oh my goodness my face is so sunburned
and wind burned
i'm so tired
tomorrow we're doing the camping we're
gonna get out there
oh we're gonna catch some more fish
i'll see you guys in the morning oh good
morning oh my back
all right guys we're at the local gas
station here in kotzebue and it's all
closed down we can't get gas
it's closed for fish day because the she
fish are in they called it a holiday
so
so
there we go
nice
there we
oh i got a go
one it's just
look at this
i think that's the biggest one we've got
yet
oh
nice
you saw that right
yeah yeah yeah he's got three others
somewhere else
that's that's huge dad one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
you're done
oh look at that yeah
look at
this was all within one hour
don't care anymore just dragging that's
dragging
confidence in my gear
ah
i've got the same piece of she fish chin
on there that i've had all day well
there we go guys
we both caught our limit that's 20 fish
plus dad let five go so we've got 25
fish in an hour and a half
not bad
look at this
oh my goodness
that is a pile of fish not too bad for
an hour and a half
i got some fish to fillet before they
all freeze solid like rocks it's going
to be cold
do a little catcher release on the
orange rod
oh there he is
[Music]
all right
you see that's what they're eating
that's why they like those big silver
spoons
um
[Music]
dan you're just tearing them up all
right you got one good size
oh that's a healthy fish
she's starting close
that is almost he's a huge installer it
is longer than the fishing rod
good job dad
nice one
yeah that
that's pretty beat up
yeah i think those rods are more fun but
the antlers are more effective i think
that's exactly right
[Music]
ah
[Music]
all right we got our fish now we need to
go make camp i can santana about here
but it's so windy i think we just get
blown off the ice
i got a better spot planned
so this is survival cabin
anybody who's out in the weather needs a
place to stay
can use it to get out of the elements
there it's a fly
a very very cold fly
go back to sleep buddy it's too early
oh
oh
just a plywood box with a couple windows
and a wood stove but man this will keep
you warm it feels really nice in here
that wind is brutal out there
hey
you want something
that's it
get a she fish with a black bean ginger
sauce
and a little bit of curry and rice yeah
give it a go see what you think
not good
you like the sheep fish
it's right
that she fish is good it's kind of like
a mix between salmon and hell yeah
well we got dinner taken care of now i
need to get these fish laid out in the
snow bank so they don't freeze in one
big clump
i can't get over how light it is this
early in the year
it's already almost 9 30 and
it's still pretty light outside
all right glasses hey look how much
brighter it is
well it's past 11 o'clock now so i'm
gonna drink a little cup of hot herbal
tea here
snuggling to bed and i'm gonna go to
sleep
but i'm gonna do a time lapse here and
uh i'll see you guys in the morning
[Music]
do
[Music]
i like the room too it's right there by
your left
this is an oatmeal with the sausage in
there
hot oatmeal on a cold warning shirt
tastes good
the last text is he doing better yeah i
know i saw you
it is another cold beautiful day
oh that arctic wind is just
there we go
that's hard
we got the sleds packed got the cabin
cleaned up
now we got about a one hour ride
across land back to kotzebue
it is nippy today
driving along that we just saw a target
go chase after it real quick
[Applause]
there we go that's the tarp again it's
freak time so you can see it's starting
to turn brown again delicious bird
yeah little furry feet to keep them warm
in the wintertime
well we've seen about half a dozen
targets but we're kind of taking too
much time getting back to town so we're
just gonna kind of get back
take care of business first
all right guys this is the elder care
facility it's an assisted living home
for the native people here in the
village and a lot of them when they are
here they don't get to eat a lot of wild
meat which is what they grew up on what
they're used to eating and so people in
the community will donate to the elders
their their game so they can have
something nice a home-cooked meal
something they're used to
so we're going to see if they want some
shee fish
well we just got to meet the cook here
and a great guy and they were excited
excited to see the she fish so we just
got to take it to the right place to get
it donated and
it's going to get put to good use
let's see
please don't judge me too bad when you
see my filet job okay
that was my first sheep
oh i am hungry i'm starting to get cold
all right guys it's been fun but it's
time to go to the airport
pull up the airport in the steel machine
carrying a gun case
now we roll in alaska
[Music]
that was a pretty awesome trip it was
very awesome well listen guys i hope you
enjoyed watching this as much as we
enjoyed doing it if you guys want to see
more amazing adventures from the outdoor
boys youtube channel make sure to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning
all right dad i'm going to bed i'll see
you tomorrow
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]